so brie uh now that and i i remember
the the spring very well
and i know it was deeply painful for
everyone on the bernie campaign where it
felt like it was this
close like right there post nevada and
then
um jim climber endorses joe in south
carolina and then the entire tide turns
and all the candidates
um uh
head a particular direction
so it's been seven eight months since
then you've now pivoted to become
an independent voice a journalist you're
producing things that you believe in
what do you see
as like the next number of steps for
progressives for trying to make some of
these
changes happen politically for yourself
individually
you know i mean you had like a
fascinating career already and you're
still just getting started
um but like i i look up and you know
there are times when i'm very optimistic
there are times when i think that the
mechanics of our system are just
desperately broken
uh and that and when you start digging
into
some of these numbers like you know an
18 percent approval rating for congress
in a 94
re-election rate you're like whoa like
how does that work and then you
you start looking at mechanical fixes um
one mechanical fix i've been pushing
very hard is ranked choice voting
and open primaries which i think would
make our politics much more dynamic and
responsive and genuine
and then you can you couldn't bully
everyone being like you're going to
waste your vote you're going to like
elect the evil or whatever it's like
well if you're ranked
voting we don't need to worry about it
anymore so let's pursue
true democratic reforms yeah i i'm a
huge
fan a huge advocate of ranked choice
voting um the number one bully pull put
to
your point the democratic party has is
if you don't vote for the lesser of two
evils you're going to make the evil win
and we have been operating on that logic
since you know
realignment and the democratic party
became what it is today
um and the republican party became the
you know
southern strategy party of white racism
that you know it emerged as
and we've been trying to struggle out of
that since the 1960s
since the 1950s and
uh i raised this question you know at
this point kind of infamously on our
podcast in an episode with noam chomsky
where i simply asked look let's assume
that donald trump presents a unique evil
and we all have to vote him out this
time
what do we do between now and 2024 to
make sure we're not in this same
situation how do we get out of this
lesser of two legalism structure
and if we are willing to pledge our
votes the democratic party no matter
what under any circumstances
i you know i thought michael bloomberg
um was a closer call in terms of who was
worse with respect to donald trump
because he's a lot more capable
and has actually enacted had actually
enacted a much more extreme
racial pogrom in new york city than
donald trump managed although he
certainly tried
um because michael bloomberg is an
incompetent unlike donald trump
um and people were you know willing to
vote for him
you know there were donnie joyce people
were saying they wouldn't vote for
bernie but they would vote for
for bloomberg if he was the eventual
nominee so what
authority do we have what what line in
the stand can we
is there if if the democrat democrats
are never willing to say enough is
enough this is not the kind of candidate
we want representing us this is not the
kind of party we are
is there any policy that they won't
throw under the bus is there any kind of
candidate that we won't accept
and if the answer is no we're go we
should expect that the party moves more
and more and more to the right over the
course of history
the way it's been doing so what's going
to stop that movement i think that
ranked choice voting is one of those
things
i think greater union participation in
figuring out how to organize
massive blocks of voters that can
meaningfully incredibly threaten
democrats to say we are going to
withhold our vote we are not going to
mobilize our population
unless you adhere to some basic
standards like the fact that 88
of democrats want medicare for all but
barely
half of the house of representatives
will co-sponsor the bill
what that like the idea the idea people
people are arguing against force the
vote who were like well it wouldn't pass
anyway
that's not an indictment of the idea of
force to vote that's a colossal
indictment
of elected representatives democratic
representatives in the house
we are in the middle of a global
pandemic where 15 million people have
just lost their employer-based health
care
all of the people who are arguing if you
like your health care you can keep it
during the the primary election should
be put on the mat
by a journalist every single day asking
have you revised your
position do you want to apologize for
misleading the public and spreading
right-wing talking points
because none of that was true and now
you have to answer to 15 million
americans
15 million who in the middle of a global
health crisis
have no recourse with respect to paying
for their health care
that's unconscionable and yet we don't
have a media apparatus who's willing to
do that
and for people like you and those in the
left who are willing to stand up and
articulate
some you know break from consensus
are ridiculed called traitors to the
party
accused of sexism or some other kind of
identity based bias
and there's no real reckoning at any
point so i do think that yes
ranked choice voting needs to be pushed
democrats will never do it because
that's the source
one of the main sources of their power
but we have to agitate for it
um we need to start going to town halls
take a lesson out of the tea parties
playbook which is was a lesson out of
solo linsky's playbook on the left
and make life uncomfortable for our
elected representatives until they
start actually representing us and that
goes for some of the people who have
been progressive champions as well it's
not about throwing them out
or saying they're terrible people or
questioning their motives
but it's about understanding that there
is a such thing as institutional creep
um when you are in office your motives
start to change
and you have an incentive in maintaining
your status and your position
and you have all these incentives to
raise money and and give money to the
parties that you can get
hierarchy and status within your
committee positions and all these kinds
of things which are important
but shouldn't come at the expense of the
people that you were elected to
represent
we need to give money to independent
candidates so that they can rely on the
people and be beholden to the people
instead of being beholden to
corporate interests we need to push for
campaign finance reform so they don't
have the option
to be dependent on corporate interests
and we all just had to stay a lot more
engaged and have
confidence have faith keep the faith
that if we do these things and we stand
together and we recognize that it's not
left right that it is top down
and the 99 stands together it is
possible for us to have a better world
it is possible and we should not let
pessimism cow us
oh you're like the antidote to cynicism
i love it anyone
anyone who needs needs a reminder
of the fact that we can do great things
uh bree's got a podcast every every week
with
virgil who's more of a virgo's more of a
downer than bree so yeah yeah should be
very
a little bit of a young yang good cop
bad cop situation
oh yeah there you are you're a very good
team um so for you
personally um i'm sure there was like a
sense of
depletion uh after the campaign and then
you've just gotten kind of your
legs underneath you in terms of um this
new podcast
and your your new uh independent media
project
would the plan be to just keep on uh
building your um voice and work until
like the the next
candidate catches fire and manages to
get your attention
yeah i mean certainly i'm interested to
see what happens electorally but i'm
also really interested to start to
explore non-electoral activism you know
there's been a little bit of a circular
firing squad on the left this past week
or two about force the vote
and to try to break out of that i'm
reaching out to union leaders and
organizers to try to come on
and give us a more um concrete sense of
how
change happens you know a lot of left
pundits like to say
well your idea doesn't work because it
really requires organizing and it
requires grassroots support i mean like
that's great but don't we play a role in
helping to germinate that
can't we do that why not right like i'm
not doing anything else i'm just a
podcaster let me let me call up the head
of my local dsa
let me write to my representative and
see if she
she can get on the record on for us to
vote you know let let me
reach out to the medicare for all
advocates let me reach out to black
lives matter advocates
let's see what does it actually take to
get 3 thousand people sitting in front
of the capitol
what does it take to organize a million
person march or the women's march let me
let me ask um
you know this woman not doing anything
this is what can do anything she doesn't
date
it's beautiful well i haven't done it
yet
you will do um all of those things are
very doable
one thing i want to just insert into
this force to vote conversation and this
is something that a member of congress
informed me of that i was like wow
that's freaking
terrible um is it's very hard to get any
vote going on the floor
because of something called the denny
hastert rule where you need the majority
of the majority party to be on board
to even introduce anything so i want you
all to
imagine being first let's say a minority
legislator so let's say you're
a democrat the senator or republican in
the house you're like well i can't force
a vote on a single thing
maybe because we're not we're not a
majority of the majority
and then i want you to imagine being a
minority of the majority party where you
also can't
get a vote on anything uh because you
know like you you don't have
i suppose it would be um you know like a
hundred and
uh 30 or 140 colleagues on board or
whatever the number is
um so that rule just strikes me is so
terrible like it just seems like such a
dysfunctional body where it's literally
like if you have the majority of the
majority then you can
actually advance things and if you don't
you can't and then you can just chill
out
[Laughter]
like yeah so it incentivizes an action
which is why this opportunity right
because the speaker can bring
a floor vote the speaker regardless of
the numbers you've got
can bring us floorboats well the speaker
is the one that enacted this rule that's
not even a rule
it's like you know it's like the
speaker's saying well i'm not going to
do it unless the majority of majority so
they clearly can do what they want yeah
and
it's an aggregating party for herself a
power rather for herself
all of it so much of what we see in
politics is that people get a little bit
of power
and they hoard it you know even you know
we talked a lot about
george bush's overreach and expansion of
executive power
and then barack obama came into office
and instead of dismantling it once you
get there like well i'm the good guy
so it's good if i have power so let me
keep let me keep what was aggregated for
me in the last administration and then
get a little bit
more and so what we get is increasingly
individuals
who are able to lord their preferences
in a very anti-democratic way over the
rest of us
which i'm going to suggest is
particularly problematic when you're
looking at
a legislative body of hundreds of people
like that that to me is like more
problematic even i mean the executive
abuses have their own
uh you know like separate category of
problem
but i feel like in a legislative body
like hoarding it at that level just
seems particularly
um egregious thank you for listening in
i hope you enjoyed this conversation if
you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
you